road to zero
school zones
we need to take extra care around
schools
children can find it hard to judge the
speed and distance of vehicles and can
be distracted
so we need to be careful around them
kia ora koto i'm adrian simpson terwaake
principal at woody school um takura
tuatahi o pakiyaka and i've been here
for the last four years as principal but
many years before that as dp and other
roles in the school
it's always
good if we can encourage families in the
community to walk and cycle to school
but at the same time it needs to be done
safely
having the school patrollers out on this
school road
has always been problematic with traffic
the amount of traffic the speed of
traffic and the visibility of the
children when they're crossing
to have the changes to the lower speed
limits that we've now got have been very
beneficial and having this crossing here
has made such a difference because it
really does slow the traffic down
and make it so much safer for the school
children who can be vulnerable at times
when they're crossing with more children
walking and cycling to school we need
them to feel safe
we want everyone to be able to enjoy
where they live
to move around and get where they need
to go safely
lower speeds can make a difference
let's work together to make that happen
[Music]